[Música]
tras la visita de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu nancy
pelosi a taiwán las tensiones y también
las hostilidades en el estrecho de
formosa que separa la isla de china han
aumentado significativamente hasta el
punto en el que taipei inició ya sus
maniobras militares con fuego real en
respuesta a los ejercicios que desde el
pasado jueves realiza beijing las
autoridades de la isla temen una posible
invasión por lo que se preparan para un
eventual defensa entretanto el ejecutivo
de jinping anunció medidas en protesta
contra eeuu por pelosi entre ellas la
suspensión de la cooperación en materia
judicial también cambio climático y
algunos mecanismos de seguridad pues
vamos a analizar las implicaciones
conjunto de jaime profesor de relaciones
internacionales en iniciada de boston ya
ex embajador de chile en china profesor
jorge gracias por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de martes en directo américa
de france 24 un gusto
hablemos entonces profesor o para
iniciar del aumento esta extensión es el
peligro que realmente representan y si
esto finalmente puede escalar o podemos
ver que se puede quedar aquí el
conflicto
si obviamente estos son los ejercicios
militares más
agresivos que ha llevado a cabo china en
toda la historia hay misiles que han
pasado por encima del territorio de
taiwán y hay barcos que han entrado en
el mar territorial de taiwán más de 100
aviones de guerra chinos han participado
en estas y son ejercicios jamás
capturados 34 días es
una ofensiva podríamos llevarlo de
ejercicio muy fuerte ahora de ahí a que
esto se vaya a traducir en un ataque a
taiwán eso no es así estos son
ejercicios
claro profesor también lo digo porque
pues hay mucho temor sobre todo en la
comunidad internacional también por lo
que vivimos en ucrania pues todos los
ejercicios militares también que empezó
rusia en la frontera entre belarús e iu
pues también pues en todo lo que
desembocó como lo vemos en la guerra él
le preguntó si esto puede tener punto de
comparación y que a lo mejor tendría que
pasar para que se pueda llevar a cabo
realmente una verdadera escalada de las
de las hostilidades no que por supuesto
nadie quiere que sea así pero pues está
este temor latente por lo que estamos
viendo en ucrania si yo creo que
obviamente se puede hacer paralelos
entre el papel de rusia en relación a
ucrania y el de chile en relación a
taiwán pero yo diría que está un poco
hay que exagerar la nota yo creo que son
el fondo cosas bastante distintas y como
dije anteriormente acá no hay que
pasarse películas ni hay que creer que
de alguna manera china
efectivamente invadir taiwán eso no va a
ocurrir lo que tiene está haciendo y
respondiendo de manera muy como dije
anteriormente asertiva a lo que
consideran es una violación de la
política de una sola china que a la cual
se había comprometido eeuu que habría
sido violada por la cita de una alta
autoridad como la señora nancy pelosi
entonces yo creo que es bueno tomar
estos ejercicios en serio pero no hay
que realmente exagerar la nota profesor
pero entonces cuando se podría digamos
hacer efectiva esta política de una sola
china que finalmente china el gobierno
de xi jinping después incorpore tal
cuando su territorio pueden pasar
muchísimos años o realmente eso se puede
quedar así digamos como está actualmente
que podría pasar digamos en este
conflicto político
muchos señalan que una fecha límite para
china sería el año 2049 que es el
centenario de la revolución china
ocurrió en 1949 y que todavía tenemos
bastante tiempo tenemos 30 años para
ello china tiene una perspectiva muy de
largo plazo no tiene apuro en este
sentido está comprometida con la
eventual lo que llama la reunificación
de china qué significa la incorporación
de tangua no lo que hoy día tiene
continental pero no tiene apuro ni esto
va a ocurrir de manera intempestiva ni
de manera apurada ellos se van a tomar
su tiempo para hacerlo de la manera
adecuada
también profesores estamos viendo que
china pues en represalia también puso
fin a una a varias cooperaciones que
tenía bilateralmente con washington en
materia de seguridad en materia de
cambio climático digamos como altera
esto está sacó operaciones en que se ha
afectado puede ser tanto eeuu como china
si es un tema bastante complejo porque
por ejemplo entre otras cosas están
eliminados las conversaciones militares
las conversaciones entre las fuerzas
armadas entre los ejércitos fuerza aérea
marina de los países cumple un papel muy
importante en evitar accidentes que
pueden ocurrir en el mar del sur de
china
o en otro lugar también se ha eliminado
las conversaciones o suspendidos las
conversaciones sobre el cambio climático
es un tema que obviamente afecta a toda
la humanidad de una que me parece a mí
bastante negativo y que ha surgido de
esta visita de la señora pelos y ahora
mi lectura es que en el corto mediano
plazo estos diálogos se van a retomar y
se van a restituir esto no va a ser algo
permanente
también profesor o como podemos ver el
comercio internacional por supuesto
afectado por estos ejercicios militares
tanto de china como de taiwán en que
afecta esto en el comercio global en
este tramo tan importante no para el
paso de mercancías si
obviamente todo estos ejercicios no
dejaron de afectar el tráfico de barcos
por esa zona el estrecho de taiwán es
uno de los que tiene más movimientos de
barcos de carga en todo el mundo
obviamente es un tema bastante serio y
yo también enfrente sería otro aspecto
económico es importante que no ha sido
suficientemente enfatizado y es el
siguiente uno de los prueba más serios
que tiene eeuu en este momento es la
inflación la inflación está del 89 por
ciento es sin embargo que eeuu no ha
eliminado los aranceles las tarifas que
estableció el presidente está sobre los
bienes que importa gran parte los bienes
que importa de china
si esto se hiciese se podría dar un
golpe es bastante certero a la inflación
el drama es que con esta
politización de las redes
interinstitucionales con esta
competencia entre las grandes potencias
que estamos viendo entre china y eeuu
nadie quiere ceder y por lo tanto eeuu
no quiere aparecer como excediendo en
esta materia y eliminando estas tarifas
que tanto daño le han hecho a la
economía de eeuu así que efectivamente
este conflicto entre las dos grandes
potencias está teniendo y con efectos
económicos muy serios